having what we're having fish and chips
for mick these little moments are
priceless
moments at one point he thought he may
never have
his covert story is one of anguish pain
and unimaginable suffering
today with his daughters he may look
well but he is still recovering over a
year on from being struck down with the
virus i was moving my daughter from uh
scotland down to elsewhere park
on the weekend it happened
michael would just kicked in full-time
i was in the hospital put me in
tentative care
to get me through the worst of it all
i was put under for three weeks
and then i had a stroke
whilst mick lay unresponsive in
intensive care at home his wife's health
was rapidly deteriorating
she too was infected but didn't survive
a tragedy unknown to make until he
finally woke up
i didn't realize then until that point
that the wife wasn't here so i thought i
was going on
so i thought i can get there no problem
then they said oh your wife died
about that time they said they'd been
they funeral and everything so i wasn't
even there what's kobe done to you mick
in terms of your life take me driving
off me
can't drive cars can't drive trucks
can't work anymore
i also got to support these two
i've got my wife just totally demolished
me
[Music]
for six months mick remained in the
royal bolton hospital he'd suffered
severe loss of mobility speech and
memory it's why specialist teams in the
stroke unit had to remind him several
times his wife had passed away
that information was again reinforced
when we went home
for the first time and
he would he was wandering around his
house opening cupboards and seeing
things that reminded him of his wife
and you know and that was very upsetting
for him
back at home and faye is now a young
carer just age 16 she's witnessed
horrors no teenager ever should it was
just so tough i was shocked and i was
upset and i was angry that this was
happening to me
and obviously
i would i would never ever wish anything
like this upon my worst enemy but
um
i just sometimes i don't think why me
why did it have to happen to us you
could do i was both i think
but
so i managed to survive
mick's story is a reminder of the
devastating effects this pandemic has
had on countless people and as covid
rips through the country again a
reminder that lives and livelihoods
remain at risk insurance rasheed sky
news bolton